hi there Steve Kaufman here as you can
see I had a haircut I guess you can call
it the haircut I was between
appointments so I decided to go into a
barber I didn't know and then I thought
I would get my hair cut short and Spike
it just for fun and so this lady went
out of that I just don't know where you
know she cut it all over the place and I
don't like spiking it so it's short but
the advantage of short hair is that it
eventually gets longer today I'm going
to talk about what I consider to be the
most important ingredient for successful
language learning and I think I'm
qualified to talk about that because I
didn't get this close enough I think
that I'm quite a successful language
learner I'm not a good golfer my wife
makes fun of me when I try to cook in
the kitchen and there's lots of things
that I don't do well but if there's one
thing that I do well it's learn
languages and I've also watched a lot of
other people learned languages and you
often hear people say oh you have a
talent for languages I don't have a
talent for languages so-and-so has a
talent for languages you know I'm sure
to some extent some people are better at
language learning than others but I
don't think the differences are that
great and I don't think that's the main
reason why some people are successful
and others are not otherwise why are
people in some countries successful
language learners everyone speaks two or
three languages in Sweden Holland
Singapore Ethiopia - just to name a few
or at different points in history in all
the Russian aristocracy in the German
aristocracy in the 19th century spoke
excellent French that was just a given
that people did that I mean I was
listening to a story about some polish
Queen in the 14th century who spoke
Hungarian polish French and God knows
what laughing I mean where is considered
normal people just do it so I don't
think there's such tremendous
differences in in basic talent level and
the difference is our attitude and we've
often talked about motivation of course
you have to be more
but I think another big thing is what I
call the willingness to accept
uncertainty I am quite happy listening
to something that I don't understand and
listen to it over and over again and and
always having the same parts of it that
I don't understand now I like to listen
and then read so that and then look up
the words I have a chance to understand
it when I go back to listen again I
still don't understand certain parts
certain parts just take longer to learn
but I have always preferred to read and
to listen to things that were authentic
real language even if I didn't
understand but I watch all kinds of
learners who have a totally different
approach they want slow language they
want it to be everything has to be
explained they want to nail down the
pronunciation right at the beginning you
know I was listening to this ESL podcast
which is very popular far more popular
than we are and they do a great job but
I would never listen to that if I were
learning it's the equivalent podcast
we're available in Russian or Portuguese
or one of the languages that I'm
learning I don't want to hear people
saying well that is a nice building I
wonder how they built the building I
don't want that and so I very quickly in
my Russian studies went to audiobooks
went to Eric I mostly went to places
where I was struggling I can remember in
my Chinese studies I had this one
audiobook version a history of the
Second World War I must have listened to
that about 15 times not to mention my
sunshine and especially where there's
rhythm in the way things are said I mean
and I don't understand it but I think
that when we learn languages we have to
connect with the language at a level of
the tsardom that the music the rhythm
the feel of the language that's what we
have to establish and trying to nail
down little bits of grammar or nail down
how something is pronounced the L and
the R if you're Japanese or tall
if you're trying to learn Chinese or you
know the Spanish under our you know
relief whatever these things will come
and you'll have an easier time of it
later on in the meantime just let it go
learn to live with uncertainty vagueness
imperfection and learn to enjoy it and I
think that all successful language
learners have that in common that they
don't mind they don't mind the
imperfection and the people who try to
pursue imperfection and get frustrated
because they can't do it they can't
remember and they can't pronounce and
they get all kinds of negatives built up
those are the unsuccessful language
learners so a short word today I was
just thinking of it as I was how I got
to ESL podcast it was medicine somewhere
I went there to listen to it and a
tremendously successful and I am sure
that the vast majority of English
learners far prefer ESL podcast to
anything that we do yet when I listen to
you know natural podcasts and of course
all the offer is the podcast natural
language and then say come to link and
look up the words you need like again I
don't want lots of explanations ESL
podcasts offers you grammar notes and
explanations and exercises and
vocabulary I don't want to do that I'll
find my own vocabulary and I'll just
listen to it and gradually absorb it I'm
the exception
most people don't agree with me but on
the other hand I am better than the
average in language train so maybe maybe
maybe it's not just me anyway I look
forward to your comments bye for now